the Joe Rogan experience in Bahrain we
weren't on the base in Bahrain we were
in town it was whatever the city isn't
bad it's almost to me more exciting that
when you would go to a place like that
already be corrupted by McDonald's
something is something ridiculously
thrilling look I would love to land
somewhere don't get me wrong I would
love to land somewhere and deal only
with the authentic culture but there's
also something kind of weird about
flying for 18 hours and landing in some
country and ordering a Big Mac and and
seeing it being served up by people who
live in this strange land different
different than you you know grew up in a
different environment different culture
different language different alphabet
who you are eating a quarter pounder in
the same place it's like there's
something about it that I like when
things don't make any sense I like when
things are haywire I like when you're
like what in the [ __ ] have you done
there's something about that that I like
and I like a Burger King in the middle
of Thailand I like it yeah I don't want
to eat there I don't want to eat there
but there's part of me that's like the
ridiculous folly of humans and their
decision-making and and and and what we
do and what we don't do I'm thrilled by
it yeah I'm thrilled by ridiculous
videos of dudes getting on a slip and
slide trying to ride a [ __ ] beer keg
down the side of a hill when you know
it's gonna go wrong I'm thrilled by that
you know there's a part of me that I'm
trying to really suppress that I'm not
thrilled by people dying from this virus
I'm not thrilled by you if you feel ill
I'm not thrilled by any of that I'm not
thrilled by anybody suffering but I'm
thrilled by a chaos I'm thrilled by the
fact that this whole system gets thrown
into a [ __ ] just a blender and spun
around and no one knows what's gonna get
spit out and a lot of these people
they're getting you're getting really
clearly revealed they're frauds these
people that are in positions of
leadership or bizarre human beings that
don't even live in reality like I was
watching Nancy Pelosi trying to dance
her way out of saying that in February
she was telling people to go to
Chinatown hang out
a good time don't worry about it like
like what you were doing the same thing
you're accusing the president of doing
you're accusing Trump of not warning
people well you didn't warn anybody
either everyone's playing gotcha with
this nobody saw what the [ __ ] was coming
like I said the [ __ ] World Health
Organization in a tweet was saying it
can't be transmitted from person to
person no one knew
see this is all this chaos of all these
people getting revealed I like it yeah I
like it there's part of it that I like I
enjoyed understand that yeah one one
thing that we have above all the people
that live before us is that we have more
access to information we see the flaws
better we see the flaws better whereas
before we were lied to and [ __ ] it
now I could see it better
it doesn't mean those flaws aren't gonna
exist but those people are gonna have to
be they're gonna have to be authentic
they're not authentic right now like
when you see someone the record will
show that I was there in Chinatown to
tell people to not be racist the record
will show you can't do that anymore you
can't do that anymore we demand you be
authentic and if you made a mistake like
that like in February look man if you
were hanging out with me in February we
were barbecue and I'll be like it's
probably the flu people are gonna get
sick they're gonna die but I'm not a
[ __ ] expert okay I'm not a politician
and if I said that I'd be like man was I
wrong here's why I thought that here's
what I wouldn't say the record will show
the reason why I said that is I want you
to not be racist to Chinese people
mm-hmm like if you believe that like
this is like some intricate plot to that
Nancy Pelosi had to sort of stop racism
against Chinese people like nonsense
right you were talking [ __ ] and the
world changed and there was the same as
I was at the Secretary of Health in New
York City well who was it that was
telling people to go out take the subway
I forget who it was but there was this
lady right a bad call right but nobody
no the World Health Organization's
telling people it can't be transmitted
from person to person at one point in
time no one knew it's a new thing you
know where mistakes made of course
they're made this is in who's the
perfect person in real time in the
middle of the [ __ ]
and Emmett crisis the person doesn't
exist they don't have access to the
information to make perfect decisions
you have to have all the information was
some of it ignored yeah because it was
conflicting information so it has to be
sifted through Friday's
hydroxychloroquine turns out that stuff
kills more people than not using it oops
yeah whoops that's not then there's some
other stuff what is the new stuff that
the nurse was telling us about yam Rams
vitamins and by the way I feel good
about you feel good about getting that
yeah antibody test yes did you know
[Applause]